la culture sur tes défiles c'est avec
Johanna Soudry bonsoir Johanna et
forcément émission spéciale consacrée à
Issa donc bien comédien de Déclic
Théâtre alors empêche culture on parle
forcément de décritères exactement donc
il s'adoune bien vous êtes déjà avec
nous
alors on va en parler donc là en face de
vous vous avez papi allant de bois de
son vrai nom
qui est donc le directeur artistique et
puis mort voilà très bien qui est aussi
comédien
issu donc de Déclic Théâtre et ça je me
tourne vers vous vous venez justement de
ce d'accord
et l'élève de Dissa Doumbia aussi aussi
voilà
les images
allez ça va être vous allez y arriver tu
viens de
comment est-ce que tu as découvert
justement
alors comment j'ai découvert l'impro
tout simplement au collège parce qu'on
avait des ateliers proposés par la
compagnie des clips théâtre et c'est un
pote à moi qui s'appelle Fouad Bouazza
qui m'a attiré par la main il m'a dit
tout ça je vous disais qu'est-ce qui se
passe il m'a dit ils savent écoute
j'ai mon frère qui a déjà fait de
l'improvisation théâtrale viens voir ce
que c'est non non il sentait que j'étais
un peu timide à l'époque et que je
m'exprimais plutôt avec les points que
avec la parole et il m'a un peu boosté
pour pour venir faire des ateliers et
mon premier prof c'était Jamel Debbouze
donc du coup j'ai fait ma première année
d'impro et que Jamel Debbouze en prof et
ce qui était hallucinant c'est qu'il y
avait tellement de gosses qui faisait de
l'impro on a été au collège Courbet il y
avait trois zones trois zones où il y
avait la zone d'histoire à l'étage la
zone d'anglais la zone du CDI c'était
Blin et on avait je sais pas combien
d'équipes dans le collège donc
aujourd'hui ça continue il y a plein de
collèges qui font des matchs impro et je
kiffe ça moi je suis au collège aussi
comme
tout et ça t'a un peu permis aussi de
d'éviter de traîner un peu dans le
quartier exactement alors ça c'est très
drôle parce que mon prof qui s'appelle
noélia King Louise on l'appelle tous
Nono et ben un jour je traînais je
traînais dans la rue et j'avais plus au
lycée mes parents ils s'en doutaient pas
puisque tous les matins je prenais mon
sac à dos et jamais je disais bonne
journée et je partais
voilà donc tous les jours je partais
comme ça et un jour je croise Nono et il
me dit tu fais quoi dehors
pas traîner ce qui c'est mieux soit tu
rentres chez toi soit tu vas à l'école
sinon au pire tu viens à la compagnie
mais tu es pas dehors quoi et donc le
lendemain matin j'ai pris mon sac je
suis ressorti de chez moi et je me suis
dirigé directement vers la compagnie et
il m'a vu arriver elle a fait ah bon bah
on va on va t'accueillir donc je suis
venu ils ont on a parlé à papi
directement et au fur et à mesure ils
m'ont dit faut que tu le dises à tes
parents faut que tu le dises à tes
parents et un jour ma mère se réveille
elle me dit est-ce que tu vas à l'école
et du coup je lui dis bah non et je suis
sorti comme un comme tous les matins
et elle m'a dit mais qu'est-ce que tu
fais je lui dis j'étais à la compagnie
des clichéâtre parce qu'il m'avait dit
qu'il fallait pas traîner et je
préférais aller là-bas et du coup elle
les a rencontrés elle a dit une pression
elle lui a dit d'accord ok il arrête
l'école mais vous en occupez comme si
c'était votre fils tenez bonne journée
au revoir
le même plan donc forcément après je
vois ça je dis là parce que sa maman
c'est quand même un personnage donc je
dis là tu assures c'est c'est pas
possible autrement en fait
non c'est papi
c'est pas ça mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
il y a ce côté famille il y a des clics
théâtre et comme je dirais presque dans
un village où on se connaît bah Nono en
tant qu'oncle peut-être aussi bon laisse
pas traîner un jeune qu'on connaît et
puis on voit ce qu'on peut faire et
effectivement après il y a le talent de
Issa qui fait la différence et qui fait
que il trouve ses places il trouve sa
marque il commence par la radio
et puis et puis voilà puis à un moment
donné je dis bah maintenant tu es prêt
pour aller plus loin
je me suis dit un jour j'ai dit ouais je
vais pas pire je craque je la radio
j'aurais pu me fait ça veut dire que tu
es prêt à quoi bah devenir comme indien
ah bon
c'est ce qui est drôle parce que on a
une relation avec Papi très forte où il
me dit en amont ce que je vais devenir
donc six mois après avoir fait de la
radio quand je suis parti de la radio il
m'a dit tu vas tu vas faire de la télé
bientôt t'inquiète pas 6 mois après je
reviens chez Papy je joue dans Brigade
Navarro je comprends pas si ce qui s'est
passé et donc à chaque fois on en rigole
aujourd'hui mais
non je suis désolé
ça marche pas enfin personnellement et
puis voilà mais ce qui est intéressant
aussi là-dedans c'est comment ça jamais
ensuite il y a il y a effectivement
sympa avec moi mais c'est aussi là il y
a indique à côté qui lui de son côté est
rencontré ça et ça fait exactement la
même chose que moi avec Andy donc il y a
cette pérennisation là qui qui fabuleuse
à déclic c'est que les grands prennent
en charge les plus jeunes et il y a
vraiment un passage qui va au-delà de la
simple culture de de
se creuser qui est Déclic Théâtre et
vraiment pris en charge par tout le
monde et ça c'est ça elle me dit
justement qui est donc comédien
aujourd'hui était avant l'élève dit ça
voilà
très jeune au collège mais c'est devenu
c'est devenu plus qu'un pote Andy on
partage beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
il est dans la même chambre c'est mignon
il est c'est un très bon comédien
d'ailleurs j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir
le mettre en scène puisque j'ai fait une
pièce de théâtre avec Andy et d'autres
comédiens de la compagnie et il m'a
vraiment je savais qu'il pouvait aller
loin mais sur cette pièce là il m'a
vraiment il m'a vraiment épaté c'était
c'était même un des moteurs de la pièce
et du coup du coup je pense que il
pourra aller très très loin
ça il est comment comme prof jugement
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors verdict les
juges verdict non c'est un très bon prof
il m'a pris de très très bonnes choses
et il passe pas par quatre chemins c'est
ça qui est c'est ça qui est bon donc du
coup si ça marche pas direct et si ça
marche et il le dit direct et c'est
aussi bien mais
et toi maintenant tu es coach aussi donc
du coup moi pour ma part je suis coach
aussi voilà et puis bah du coup moi papi
c'est mon papy et ça c'est mon papa
il est même animateur aussi animateur
dans la compagnie mais aussi animateur
télé sur sur le Big James et
sur Canal J avec d'autres d'autres
personnes de la compagnie ou ou des
personnes qui ont effleuré la compagnie
comme Julie Galibert et Antoine rabot
donc pour moi c'est c'est que c'est que
de la fierté de de partager
ces moments avec ces gens-là puisque je
me dis on fait de la scène ensemble et
après on va diffuser tout notre art sur
toute la France donc c'est un bonheur il
y a beaucoup de talents qui sont passés
par Déclic Théâtre forcément un petit
résumé en images Johanna vous avez
compilé les les artistes qui aujourd'hui
sont connus reconnus qui ont commencé à
déclic
quel est le point commun entre Jamel
Debbouze
laurent Ournac
ou encore Arnold sa mère
il n'y a plus de papier
et bien tous sont passés par la case
Déclic Théâtre une compagnie de théâtre
pas comme les autres puisqu'elle
cultivent le théâtre d'improvisation un
genre venu tout droit du Québec et c'est
à Trappes que Déclic Théâtre a vu le
jour en 1993 à l'époque Jamel est
collégiens et découvre l'improvisation
grâce au direct artistique de la
compagnie Alain Degois surnommé papi
Jamel dira d'ailleurs qu'il doit tout à
cet homme car papi finalement c'est un
découvreur de talent exemple avec Arnaud
de sa mère avez-vous entendu parler de
cet humoriste régulier de l'émission on
me demande qu'à en rire présenté par
Laurent Ruquier la rencontre de sa mère
avec papy a été décisive pour la
carrière du jeune artiste quand à 25 ans
26 ans tu lâches ton boulot un CDI avec
un salaire fixe et que tu veux avoir ton
et que tu veux faire du spectacle ton
métier la première chose la première
question c'est de savoir comment je vais
bouffer et Papi m'a tout de suite
rassuré là dessus et puis il m'a donné
il m'a tout de suite montré beaucoup de
confiance et il m'a tout de suite
mais tout de suite fait comprendre que
c'était pas une décision
inepte et donc
ça a été très important pour moi et la
success story de déclicate ne s'arrête
pas là à l'affiche de la comédie beurre
sur la ville le comédien Issa Doumbia
lui aussi
issu de la compagnie d'improvisation
quand je suis arrivé dans l'atelier mon
prof c'était Jamel Debbouze qui est
aujourd'hui un grand acteur grand
comédien et que tout le monde connaît
des clichés vraiment c'est
c'est vraiment ma seconde famille parce
que ils ont toujours été là au moment où
il fallait dans ma vie quand j'étais
timide donc je suis fait des cours avec
eux après quand je traînais dans la rue
ils étaient là et après quand j'ai voulu
vraiment faire ce que je voulais donc
être complètement comédien et ben ils
ont encore été là depuis peu Andy mort
Antoine rabot et Julie ghalibert trois
anciens élèves de Déclic Théâtre ont
rejoint la chaîne Canal J pour animer
une émission jeunesse déjantée peut-être
suivront-ils les pas de Sophia Aram qui
adolescente improvisait aux côtés de
Jamel Debbouze après avoir débuté dans
l'audiovisuel avec Arthur la comédienne
s'épanouit désormais sur les planches
alors même si des clics 4 ressemble à
une réelle Star Academy c'est loin du
star system que la compagnie est obligé
de se battre au quotidien pour obtenir
des subventions et assurer ainsi la
survie de sa structure
on a vu beaucoup alors on a vu beaucoup
de visages connus mais ce n'est qu'un
aperçu donc parmi parmi ces célébrités
Jamel Debbouze et puis ça tombe bien
donc sur le plateau
est-ce qu'il y a un secret pour que
justement tous les élèves de déclic
réussissent aussi bien c'est pas
forcément un secret c'est que
Saint-Quentin est un vrai creuset
d'artiste je crois et que et toute ce
travail autour de l'improvisation
théâtrale nous a permis effectivement
d'apercevoir des gens de de peut-être
d'ouvrir des portes à certains et et
encore une infime partie je dirais de de
Saint-Quentin je pense qu'il y a il y a
plein d'autres artistes encore qui sont
qui sont à venir et voilà après il y a
un vrai travail de fond c'est la
pérennisation voilà là on est sur Djamel
premier l'équipe junior dont a fait
partie de Jamel c'est c'est 91 donc ça
fait 20 ans c'est 20 ans de travail avec
les aînés qui prennent en charge les
autres donc toute cette pérennisation là
fait que oui on a
aussi des exigences des exigences
artistiques qu'on partage avec des
élèves et puis qui font leur chemin à
déclic pourdans il a commencé à 11 ans
quel âge taille 29 maintenant voilà donc
c'est des tragies de vie c'est aussi des
traces des qu'on accompagne je crois que
c'est ça vraiment la réussite avec comme
sa mère l'a dit c'est un moment donné
ils ont en face de quelqu'un qui leur
fait confiance j'ai confiance dans ce
que tu as à me donner à voir j'ai
confiance dans dans dans peut-être dans
dans ta particularité et c'est celle là
qu'il faut mettre en avant et puis moi
je suis là pour les booster pour aller
plus loin et puis et puis attendez il y
a des trucs formidables quand je me
retrouve en scène avec des gens qui ont
commencé avec moi il y a 10 ou 15 ans et
qu'on est dans la même pièce de théâtre
c'est le partage avec qui ça sur le
plateau quand lui il fait mon beau-père
c'est absolument
délicieuse délicieux c'est c'est pour
moi c'est je savoure ces moments là on
se retrouve en quintet tous ensemble
quel bonheur quel bonheur j'ai une
petite remarque
arque on remarque il y a beaucoup de
garçons mais pour moins de filles c'est
dû à quelque chose ça ou c'est
simplement
un phénomène culturel après il y a
effectivement
il y en a d'autres qui réussissent Kumba
balle on pourra en citer plusieurs si
c'est bas si c'est Yatera qui qui va
être bientôt à la Merise là en décembre
donc oui il y a aussi des jeunes femmes
qui qui passent c'est plus dur pareil
c'est un milieu un peu macho donc c'est
plus compliqué mais par des clics
effectivement il y a une équipe d'impôts
c'est autant de filles que de garçons
que des comédiens et aussi un garçon que
j'ai eu aussi en élève qui s'appelle
Mathieu longade qui est devenu avocat
pour pour les comédiens justement et il
est aussi un petit peu encore comédien
d'ailleurs il a joué sur parce que je
vois depuis tout à l'heure
il a joué dans dans ce film
voilà une petite question aussi la
réussite et l'efficacité donc de
déclices ne sont plus à prouvés mais il
y a quand même encore des difficultés
notamment pour obtenir certaines
subventions certaines salles
d'ailleurs une seule Robert canal vert
monsieur vous connaissez depuis que je
suis tout petit et je suis venu vous
voir il y a pas si longtemps vous m'avez
promis qu'on allait pouvoir s'arranger
pour avoir des salles pour jouer mon
spectacle j'ai toujours pas joué mon
spectacle ici c'est donc les petites
annonces dit ça donc qui cherche une
salle si vous avez un contact c'est vrai
c'est vrai que c'est aujourd'hui bon il
y a toutes ces phénomène de crise il y a
une vraie baisse des subventions il y a
moi je crois que la culture c'est c'est
le seul moyen de pour nous en banlieue
aussi de de pas de pas se renfermer de
pas de passe cloisonner de pas être dans
les dans tous ces fermement qui peut y
avoir chez les jeunes et autres le repli
communautaire tout ça il n'y a pas il
n'y a que c'est que la culture qui peut
arriver à faire en sorte qu'on sorte de
ça et qu'on aille vers la vers l'avant
donc effectivement encore une fois des
clips théâtre pour rayonner sur
Saint-Quentin a besoin d'un lieu et
c'est difficile c'est compliqué mais on
avance je crois qu'on avance je crois
que monsieur canalbert a entendu ça donc
il y a des choses qui qui avance de ce
côté là effectivement on va peut-être y
arriver on manque de moyens c'est c'est
sûr je vois bien que la compagnie est en
difficulté en ce moment c'est vrai je
j'ose espérer que c'est une mauvaise
passe j'ose espérer aussi que des que
des des structures privées il y a pas
que le foot à soutenir regardez les
profils symboliques positifs qu'on crée
pour la ville pour
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc peut-être
que oui il y a des il y a des
footballeurs qui valent le coup mais il
y a des comédiens qui valent le coup il
y a une compagnie qui en qui en produit
donc bah peut-être qu'il y a des il y a
des il y a des entreprises qui vont
peut-être aussi se dire bah je vais
peut-être aussi investir là alors on les
attend on est on est les bienvenus ils
savent ils savent où nous trouver et
voilà on crée du profit symbolique
positif aussi nous moi ce que je trouve
quand même hallucinant c'est que
j'arrive à jouer facilement dans Paris
c'est à dire je demain je demande une
salle dans Paris et je la trouve et
aujourd'hui dans un endroit où j'ai
grandi où je rappelle tout le temps que
je viens de cette ville ou que je viens
de du 78 et ben c'est plus compliqué et
je trouve ça quand même très très
alarmant et je me dis que si on est
obligé d'aller sur Paris pour s'exprimer
bah c'est un peu compliqué surtout quand
tout notre public se trouve dans le 78
alors conclure cette séquence on va
juste laisser demander M10 regard sur ce
qui a été dit entre papi et Issa
justement le même point de vue
ça ira vite pour la conclusion comme ça
merci
il y a et en plus il y a la relève qui
est derrière c'est à dire que il y a
énormément de jeunes qui sont prêts à
grimper qui ont la niaque la dalle comme
on dit donc
voilà il faut les soutenir à fond et il
faut les soutenir à fond merci Johanna
pour cette page culture merci à tous les
trois d'être venu indique qu'on retrouve
sur Canal J donc pour le jump
quotidienne merci d'être venu au revoir
l'affiche de législata c'est jeudi et
vendredi à faire à Élancourt 20h30 quand
même sur le territoire et merci d'être
venu parce que vous êtes en pleine
répétition voilà merci beaucoup ils
savent vous restez sur ce plateau ça a
toujours à la fiche de beurre sur la
ville depuis mercredi dernier beurre sur
la ville justement qu'en avez-vous pensé
réaction à la sortie des sales propos
recueillies pas et le dis-moi
c'est très bien
super pas terrible
donc
c'était un peu cliché on va dire
beaucoup de postiche tout ça donc bon un
peu déçu par rapport à mon annonce bah
moi je trouve ça bien parce que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont racistes en
France aujourd'hui et je trouve que par
rapport à ce film là on voit que un
arabe ou un noir ça peut faire pareil
que les Français bah moi ça m'a plu nous
ça nous a bien amusé et bon il y a tout
un tas d'acteurs qui viennent pour des
petits rôles c'était c'était bien bon je
m'attendais à mieux je m'attendais à
mieux
après
bon il est marrant mais oui je
m'attendais à mieux
moi quand même c'est sympa bah c'est
bien c'est marrant c'est original ça
change de la police de ce qu'on peut
penser nous les jeunes je m'attendais un
gros navet puis finalement c'est assez
moyenne je mettrais 11 sur 20 quoi c'est
assez rigolo bah il était bien il était
marrant
ça et puis c'est bien que ça passe aussi
dans les quartiers difficiles il était
très intéressant et ça montrait bien les
différences qu'on a
dans toutes les villes ici
l'intégration